ya vimos el mecanismo para una reacción
de eliminación de dos en este vídeo nos
enfocaremos a las bases y la región
selectividad
recordemos que el carbono alfa es el que
está conectado a nuestro halógeno y el
carbono beta está unido a ese el doble
enlace se formará entre nuestro carbono
alfa y el beta en una eliminación de 2
no se forma un carbó catión no hay por
qué preocuparse desde arreglos aquí
veamos una de las posibles bases que
podemos usar para esta reacción
normalmente para este tipo de reacciones
se usa como base un alcock sido
una el cocido es una base con jugada a
un alcohol por ejemplo el stock sido de
sodio el stock sido de sodio consta de
un castellón de sodio y un año net óxido
que es un oxígeno unido a ch todos ch3
el oxígeno tiene tres pares de
electrones solitarios a su alrededor lo
que le da una carga forma negativa
este es el tóxico de sodio lo escribiré
el óxido
de sodio
y se puede abreviar como enea o el de
enea
así es como lo verán escrito en un
mecanismo y este año net óxido está
conjugado a la base de etanol si nos
fijamos en el año net óxido al añadir un
protón a esa base nos quedará la
molécula de etanol esta base es muy
parecida al famoso hidróxido de sodio
que usamos en química general tiene a
más o menos son muy parecidos la única
diferencia es el grupo stihl aquí en el
et óxido de sodio el stock sido de sodio
es una base más orgánica que el
hidróxido de sodio busquemos otra
posible base para la reacción de
eliminación de dos veamos esta molécula
aquí tenemos un grupo textil y luego
tenemos un oxígeno cargado negativamente
esta vez nuestra ocasión será el potasio
así que se llama termo
óxido de potasio
termot óxido
de potasio entonces aquí tenemos un
grupo textil y esta será la base con
jugada de botana
si protón amos alter botox sido obtener
y amo shelter butano la abreviación este
de un vodka esto es el termo tóxico de
potasio estas son dos posibles bases
existen más pero estas son las más
comunes ahora veamos cómo estas bases
afectan la región selectividad en una
reacción de eliminación de dos
regios
selectividad es decir en qué región de
la molécula ocurrirá la reacción
dibujemos los reactivos por aquí este
será nuestro alumno del kilo
entonces la región selectividad de esta
reacción después nos preocupamos por la
base que podemos hacer pero por ahora si
hacemos reaccionar este alumno de
alquilo con una base fuerte cuáles serán
los posibles productos primero
identifiquemos nuestros carbonos alfa y
beta el carbono unido a nuestro halógeno
es el carbono alfa y los carbonos junto
a este pueden ser los carbonos beta
llamaré a este beta 1
este es el carbono alfa y a éste le
llamaré carbono beta 2 y aquí tenemos un
tercer carbono será el carbono beta 3
será el beta 3 dibujemos entonces los
tres posibles productos que resultarán
con el beta 1 con el beta 2 y con el
beta 3 la primera es para the town ésta
será con beta 2 y esta es para beta 3
entonces si uno
hace fuerte reacciona con el protón de
la posición de town o el doble enlace se
formará entre el carbono alza y el
carbono z1 conocer el producto bueno
aquí tenemos nuestro anillo de
ciclohexano y tenemos un grupo metilo el
doble enlace se forma entre el carbono
alfa y el beta 1
así nos queda el primer producto ahora
para la posición beta 2 otra vez ponemos
nuestro anillo y nuestro grupo metil el
doble enlace se forma entre el carbono
alfa y el beta 2
así nos queda el segundo producto y
nuestra tercera posibilidad es que el
doble enlace se forme entre carbono alfa
y el beta 3 quedaría algo así muy bien
vamos a ver con la posición beta 1 y
beta 2 se obtuvo la misma molécula si la
nombramos obtendríamos exactamente el
mismo nombre entonces para esta reacción
sólo hay dos productos analicemos ahora
la estabilidad de los productos si nos
fijamos en el producto que se obtiene
por la vía beta uno o beta 2
identificamos si es un al que no mono de
3 o tetra sustituido si observamos el
doble enlace aquí hay un hidrógeno lo
mismo por acá ya podemos ver que es un
al que no 3 sustituido ahora veamos este
producto qué grado de sustitución tiene
este al que bueno
este lado tenemos un hidrógeno y otro
por acá así que este es un al que no te
sustituido entonces tenemos un al que no
three sustituido y un al que no ve
sustituido
sabemos que el tri sustituido es más
estable este será el producto que se
formará en mayor cantidad también se le
llama productos sites y este es el
producto site
para este caso usaremos stock sido de
sodio como base escribiré el stock sido
de sodio por acá entonces si usamos el
'toque' sido de sodio como base
obtendríamos una gran cantidad del
producto tree sustituido el sánchez y en
menor cantidad sería el di sustituido
pero si usáramos tributó óxido de
potasio como base es más fácil obtener
él al que no di sustituido si dibujamos
el término óxido de potasio por acá ya
sabemos cómo es aquí tiene una carga
negativa es muy voluminoso los grupos
metil de aquí hacen que sea una base
voluminosa lo que dificulta que se
involucre en algunas situaciones en este
caso irá por el carbono beta aquí hay un
poco de dificultad estética la base
tomará a uno de los protones en beta 3
entonces si usamos una base con
dificultad estética obtendremos el
producto menos
sustituido a este se le llama producto
de hoffman
hoffman
entonces el al que no de sustituido es
el producto hoffman solo si usamos el
término óxido de potasio obtendremos
mayor cantidad del producto de
sustituido y el tri sustituido se
obtendrá en menor cantidad siempre hay
que elegir la base que nos convenga
dependiendo de la región de la molécula
en la que queramos que ocurra la
reacción